how's that trip around the world going
grunkle Stan and grunkle Ford have you
made up from all those silly brotherly
fights we sure hope that you're having a
great time on the stand of war and we're
sure soos is doing a great job running
the mystery shack but since you've been
gone we've been doing a lot of thinking
there are some things about gravity
falls that just don't add up and we have
some theories gravity falls might have
ended years ago but we're still huge
fans and there are a ton of fan theories
about the show all over the Internet
here are some of the best theories fans
have come up with although some have
been disproven along the way we can't
deny that they once made a whole lot of
sense bill wrote the journals in gravity
falls there were three journals that
were key to bringing forward back from
the other dimension and there are lots
of theories about who actually wrote
these journals supposedly all three
journals were written by Stanford Pines
aka grunkle Ford I began to keep a
journal journal number one is all about
ford's early life in gravity falls with
lots of paranormal information journal
number two has all supernatural items
and journal number three is basically a
catalogue of all the creatures some
people think that bill cipher actually
wrote all of them he always seemed to be
at the root of everything as a powerful
diamond he could have written his
journals and then he could have either
conjured the pines twins or just
manipulated them into his big plan after
all we know that memories can be altered
in gravity falls bill would definitely
be the one who would know how to defeat
himself the show never explained how
Ford knew some of these things in the
journals but build new all of it or
maybe it was dipper we love any theory
involving time travel and once gravity
falls introduced time-traveling
abilities everything changed there is
basically nothing out of the realm of
possibility dipper is always around to
save the day and he knows how to time
travel but things always end up kind of
warped when he does gravity falls takes
place in 2012
dipper learned everything about life in
this crazy town let's say that he
returns to the future he knows that
gravity falls needs to be saved from
bill so he writes the journals then
travels back in time to 1982
that's the date that's plastered all
over the town he could also go back a
few years earlier when weird events
first started happening
he changed his Ford's memory before Ford
gets the metal in his brain to stop
memory changes and he leaves the key to
saving gravity
Falls with him the journals get lost
after Ford goes missing
but dipper is the key to finding the
last journal which saves the town
coincidence we aren't so sure
this journal told me there was no one in
gravity falls I could trust bill is
still alive this is probably the most
popular fan theory out there after all
how do you kill a demon in the series
finale bill reveals his master plan he
wants to control all of space and time
and he is set on destroying this
dimension but some events from 30 years
ago is keeping him stuck in gravity
falls the pines twins trick him into
entering Stan's mind and Ford erases
Stan's memory this destroys bill or does
it bill cries out demon gibberish and
several fans have deciphered his words
by playing it in Reverse she spells
axolotl them says my time has come to
burn I invoked the ancient power that I
may return that definitely sounds like
he's preparing to come back again
and what about axolotl well axolotls our
salamanders that can regrow body parts
that is the sort of power bill would
need to come back he might have also
spelled zelada land just screamed the a
is a lottle is an Aztec god associated
with fire the underworld monsters and
twins those are all pretty relevant to
gravity falls so he might be invoking
the power for God to return nuclear
apocalypse before it was disproven at
the end of season 2 one of the biggest
fan theories was that gravity falls was
suffering from the results of nuclear
fallout throughout the show it was said
that something massive happened 30 years
ago and that things had been strange
ever since I'm gonna thank you after
what you did 30 years ago the government
didn't know how to process the event and
bill kept trying to make sense of it all
he wanted to find out what was keeping
him trapped in gravity falls
many fans believed in the nuclear
apocalypse theory because well it
explained a whole lot but this theory
was debunked at the end of season 2 when
we found out that in 1982 Stan Ford
attempted to merge dimensions only to
end up pulling the plug
regardless the nuclear apocalypse theory
totally checked out for a number of
reasons it's all Illuminati it seems
like every conspiracy theory has
something to do with the Illuminati
some people believe there's a shadow
organization running the world they're
an ancient group called the Illuminati
there are people who think that they
control governments and the economy
people even think that they make big
international events happen one of their
supposed symbols is a pyramid with an I
doesn't that sound familiar bill cipher
is exactly that symbol the secret
society and gravity falls is called the
Society of the blind eye stan is also
believed to be a member of this group he
wears a fez and lots of secret
Brotherhood's wear those there is
definitely some Illuminati influence
here but is the show making fun of
illuminati conspiracies or is it
actually something more sinister like
propaganda or warning
who knows what do you miss most about
gravity falls let us know in the
comments thanks for watching give us a
big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to the things we'll catch you
next time
[Music]